hi I'm Nicolas be this is matt welch
we're doing ask a libertarian 2012 in
celebrating the forthcoming paperback
publication of the Declaration of
Independence Andy and Wauwatosa asks by
email what role do you see for a
libertarian party as well as quasi
libertarian efforts within the GOP going
forward particularly on a state level on
a place such as New Hampshire where the
free straight state project has had some
success in the State House we've got a
lot of questions like this we always do
and our kind of answer in the book is
sort of letting the thousand flowers
bloom I mean I'm heartened whenever
people are trying to use the rotting
husks of the two major parties to make
them more responsive to their needs
which usually means making them more
libertarian for the Republicans it means
making them more serious about cutting
spending and as opposed to talking about
it and making them even serious about
cutting military spending which they
haven't wanted to do for a long time on
the Democratic side it means making them
serious about the concerns of the
democratic base on things like the drug
war which most liberals loathe and
rightly so so that's one aspect the Free
State Project is awesome it's a bunch of
if people don't know it look up freaky
NAND go out and see what our our freaky
friends are doing up there they're
taking over local government and
changing lots and and that's very
interesting there's people who use and
we talk about a lot about this the kind
of technology of Independence to work
outside of politics cuz politicians are
are lame and they're often times trying
to obstruct you and to to kind of opt
out and create little windows of freedom
whether its medical marijuana whether
it's school choice homeschooling
internet schooling all these types of
ways that we can opt out of the current
system and create demonstration projects
for freedom so I say use all of the
above there isn't one single way I am
heartened that this year that there's
going to be a pretty good chance that
the Libertarian Party will get a bigger
share of the vote than it has in a long
time in the presidential race yeah I'm
all for working around
politics or parties because they they
get in the way of all kinds of problems
but as matt said things are looking
pretty good in many ways the LP has i
think its most electrifying and
interesting candidate in Gary Johnson
running for president as they've seen in
many many years at least going back to
Ron Paul in 88 when you see the recent
votes in California say in San Jose and
San Diego where the voters said hey
politicians were sick of paying more and
more for lavish benefits health benefits
retirement benefits for city workers
they've got to pay more in to their
share of you know of their retirement
benefits I think that's a good sign
we're going to be pushing on all ends
and the important thing is to recognize
politics are important but it's not the
only way to express yourself politically
you